yo bootleg kid podcast
episode number not sure to be honest
somewhere in the in the about to hit 40.
close to 40. you know what i'm saying
uh we've got special guest haiti baby in
the building thanks for having me dog
west coast
what's going on new uh album trap art
yes sir
dropping january 29th january 29th
that's that [ __ ] that's
that's next friday man so uh we got to
talk i want to know man
so you came up to me in a dj head show
yeah about a year and a half ago
let's come on come on did the freestyle
come on
and it went [ __ ] crazy yeah it was it
was two ways they could have went like
you already know
yeah no after it was done me and head
talked to we're like man this shit's
either about to go viral as [ __ ] or it's
gonna no one's gonna [ __ ] with it yeah
and it went crazy
yeah um first of all talk about your
approach
into because you're a smart guy yeah so
did you know what you were doing you're
a smart guy um
i knew what i was doing of course i
didn't think it was gonna land me a
reread feature
or meek mill follow chrissy teigen
that's how you pronounce her name
chrissy teigen yeah okay i wanna mess
that up um
i didn't think it was gonna do all that
i thought i was gonna get a viral buzz
you know how quick
you know how you go viral and the buzz
goes away like the
yeah that stamp always can be like i can
stop making music next year and my name
will still pop up somehow and
that just keeps people like oh i never
heard this kill me check the spotify
extremes go up like
the the pros and cons to the free to the
freestyle when i wrote out my own list
about it it was so many pros
like it was so much positivity came
after like i went gold
because of that i gained 122 followers
because of it
so it's just it was a weird experience i
came to you with 50k followers
yeah so bro [ __ ] went up after that
that was dope it was i mean i got i got
bashford i got but i never been the type
to run away from pressure right
it's probably because i play sports most
likely but [ __ ]
is what it is and um i'm looking forward
to
i'm looking forward to my future because
i'm just evolving now as a man
yeah it's crazy because you know i
remember
just like the when diesel camaro talked
about it on show
time and then like you said rihanna
chrissy teigen was like
she she was like yeah she was the
biggest was she the first
i don't know but she was like going
going hard for that freestyle she was
like i can't stop watching it
yeah a lot of artists have some good
comments sway lee
lil yachty mcmill posted it mcmillen
posted it but a lot of the newer
generational artists had a lot of good
comments of course oh heads say feedback
always going to be stern there's yeah
there's either there's no wrong with
that though
yeah if there's some people who say you
go on facebook i still get tagged to
this day it'll be like the worst
freestyle ever
right and then some people thought it
was [ __ ] crazy the best freestyle
ever
right right right right hey take it you
hate it eleven i don't really
you're familiar what were the cons of
the freestyle um
the my crowd around me my back home
people you know
seeing people fold seeing people like
you stand by my side when it when you
see oh riri and mcmillan
standing by my side right before that he
was quick to leave so
it was it was a good way to catch all
the catch all the snakes in the land you
know what i'm saying
but other than that like the pros
outfield it like it just it was just so
much good stuff happened happening after
that like
i was able to i was able to actually
like
create a whole new sound off of that
like off of that
like but i you i got a shout out to
empire and ghazi like i'm able to be
free with my artistic side
dress how i want to dress do what i want
to do right even if somebody says
oh that's not right you make your own
suggestions but as an artist i'm free
i'm not controlled so i can do what i
want you know what i'm saying so shout
out to them for
even allowing me to go to go up there
and um you release the [ __ ] cuz i know
[ __ ] like oh we ain't gonna
release it
but hey it made my career you know some
part of my legacy no no yeah
i think that there was a very we were
all
at the end of the freestyle very uh
we we didn't know what the [ __ ] we were
very confused your face is total that's
all i need but you ain't
you ahead had some good friends now yeah
yeah yeah you talk to me all the time
yeah
i think it it it was uh positive though
man i think people i think at the end of
the day like you said i kind of laid the
groundwork for you kind of
you from there you could do anything you
lit like if when people think about it
from there
like you can drop songs like how i did
blue dragon where
go under 3 000 completely off go off the
off the
off the reservoir off the red you know
because i'm not your regular rapper so
right
i created my own box and now i'm living
in it um
on the new album you got jack boy and
why clef so talk to me because obviously
both haitians
yeah why clef is like the god though
yeah you know what i'm saying yeah shout
out to white cliff you got him talking
that [ __ ] on the album
how did you guys like how did that play
happen because that's what he knew about
me before the freestyle
okay so as soon as my instagram name
popped up hey baby he already he tapped
in locked in
like giving me free game a lot of advice
um giving me books to read like oh wow
dude not giving me books like telling me
some books i should look up like
just a uh a uncle in the industry you
know what i'm saying
now how me and jack boy met of course he
signed the empire of course yeah
you know family business bringing them
yeah they're probably linked up and you
guys like it
like everything else and but what
artists realize you know a lot of people
in the in the industry always say
oh these rap [ __ ] is fake it's faking
the game but it's up to who you mess
well with so i mesh well with jack
you know that's it's my that's me
personally me and him mesh well so
that's why it seems so good on track did
you make a
conscious effort to only have haitians
featured on the album or was that by
coincidence
by coincidence okay i think you'll see
in line
oh my fault but yeah
so it was coincidence yeah i mean [ __ ]
talk about the title trap art because i
feel like
you're like you said you're like an
artist artist you could really do
anything
and and i feel like that's kind of a
dope title for
if you were to just kind of box in your
genre
give it a name yeah exactly but trap in
in
my generation is always thought when you
think of trap you think of like down
south
of course you think of like g-z-t
exactly
my version of trap is like the west
coast trap the sugar freeze the two
shirts of the world
and you know what i'm saying stuff like
that and artistic side it's just
me being me that's where you get just me
being me i might
one track i may do something you know
i'm saying or go or stay standard you
never know what you go get with me
do you think that um i was gonna say
being out of stockton in stockton for
people who don't know is
it's in northern california um
there's some other artists out of
stockton that are doing their thing yeah
embinel
uh there's some something there's more
too as well um
but do you do you think that it's like
harder coming out of a city like
stockton to break in the industry
because
it's not record like you know when
people think of california outside of
california they think la or san
francisco and that's it
hey me and nell making it easy for cats
we hope we open the door
it's up to them to kick it down you know
saying kick down all the hinges you know
what i'm saying
we open the door so it's nothing's easy
in life
but that's a part of success you have to
be uncomfortable you have to be
comfortable being uncomfortable
basically you know what i'm saying so i
give a lot of game on my page i show
y'all i'll show y'all me working out all
the time i show y'all me in the studio
so it's like yeah people got to pay
attention to the work ethic because
i'm with empire so i'm i'm going through
artist development in
my internal and external on my own no
one's telling me to do this i'm doing on
my own you got to want this
you know you can't just wake up and i'm
gonna be a rapper dude where do you come
from what's your lifestyle
do you know what i'm saying you gotta
make people care right yeah you gotta
make
it got to be believable one thing about
poc he made you believe
right you know i'm saying he gave me
hope one thing about jay-z he wrapped
with a plan
he always wrap with a plan so you got to
be prepared when you coming into this
game
so you say i have intention with
everything you do have intention with
everything you do
but i would like to say one thing you
don't just have to be an artist there's
so many positions in this industry oh of
course
people think that you if you're not like
you got to be a rapper like there's so
much other [ __ ] you could do
right because rapping is the most
dangerous dangerous position to be in
right now it is yeah for sure yeah man
it's been it's been a crazy look
last few years yeah rp all the ones who
pass away too yeah we've lost a lot of
people man
um so your influence has got to be crazy
because like you you are you mentioned
andre earlier
yeah you know when you listen to your
music you could hear some sugar-free
[ __ ] the freestyle were about to drop i
i heard some reminisce of some of that
you know what i'm saying you're
definitely gonna hear the west coast
um talk about your influences man um my
influence has always changed if that
made
any sense like i've never listened to
jay-z
until 2020. you know what i'm saying
really i never
we know i know his records but you never
like tapped in never
like actually really i know you're right
i know word for a couple of songs but i
don't know i hear what you're saying
the jay-z that you know right right
right now i'm saying i know nipsey of
course it's just played to me all the
time from the west coast i know 40
it's played to me all the time it's
familiar music but i start venturing on
so this
this year i went back into some oldies
in my catalog guys to listen to that i
forgot about like the ushers confession
album
50 cent get richer die trying um
even the pleasure plea album you know
hey pleasure pee
man pleasure pleasure peter p5 pretty
ricky had to run man you know what i'm
saying
t fly t fly fly another guy who's
out of out of la who i i really hoped
would have been bigger but he definitely
kicked down some like sonic
sonic doors for a lot of people like he
was doing a lot of [ __ ] before live
i know you know a rider when you see it
yeah talented no he's an alien for sure
for sure
so we're uh breaking down this video
we're not breaking it down we're taking
a break in the video
to tell you all about our sponsors odd
socks all right listen man uh
oddssocksofficial.com
the [ __ ] was that bro uh it was like a
[ __ ] pomeranian hair floating in the
air
anyway odd socksofficial.com keyword
bootleg kev
go over there get you some socks and
you'll save 20 off if you use that
keyword they got south park
license they got some ghostbusters pimp
c
mike tyson really the one that i really
care about is they got that wwe license
you can get these awesome nwo socks
and then they got their odd socks basics
you know for all the basic [ __ ] get
you some basic socks
even though they are very comfortable
they're probably the most comfortable
socks
actually not probably definitively the
most comfortable socks i've ever put on
my feet
yes all right and that goes for all
types of socks
so go to oddssocksofficial.com get some
socks by the way
spongebob socks they're kind of fly
right christmas time's on the way
use the keyword boulet kev 20 off
oddssocksofficial.com
support us by supporting odd socks let's
go
um you talked about rihanna tapping in
did you have any sort of correspondence
with anybody like did you chop it up
with chrissy teigen
or like no i didn't get no phone calls
with
the only person did you talk to what was
rereading her people's
they were they're super cool they're
super cool you know what i'm saying um
me keep me in the dm
on that hype like me hit me like like
that's why i never asked him yo what's
up with the verse or begging and stuff
he hit me from the hype i'm watching
just know that
so that was all i needed i was like wow
that's cool you feel me co-sign is good
enough
i take that as a cool song you ain't got
to go on the internet and say my name on
the time but
if he tells you he's watching you yeah
you're just watching that's all i you
know attention is a lot attention
getting equal to
you know what i'm saying you can be
wearing my merch one day a hundred
percent
hey and yo me and me and head need our
cut from your merch by the way
oh hey shout out burner too oh yeah
burner that's that's family right there
shout out to cookies
are you are you a big smoker i don't
smoke but i'm i love
everything about weed i love it i'm for
it but i'm just going through a personal
break because i've been on my workout
so you've been you've been chilling out
on that just been chilling out no
drinking no smoking i'm a year
not doing nothing so you um you've been
working out getting in shape and [ __ ]
talk about your like are you on any sort
of diet or anything or just just being
healthier
my diet five meals a day not super big
place
right breakfast lunch and dinner but
snacks in between okay you know what i'm
saying
so i had to up it because i was working
out
last year like january until mid to may
i wasn't seeing no improvement maybe
because i was looking at mirror maybe it
was illusion
i wasn't seeing no improvement once i
start eating more drinking more water
you know what i'm saying i think people
there's like a misconception that if you
eat less
like you should lose and obviously if
you're eating a [ __ ] ton of food you'll
lose some weight you'll hit a
you'll hit some sort of wall i think if
you like you said those little mini
meals kind of helps your metabolism keep
going right what even even if you feel
like you're fat this is the thing people
feel like
women just stop eating right that's not
gonna work because all your body is
doing
is eating the muscle that's what creates
more fat you know i'm saying you eat and
then you work out and you're giving your
body
food and you're now you're working out
and now you're giving your body time to
expand
so no particular diet just eating better
i'm eating better i'm just eating way
better you ain't on the keto wave or no
no
[ __ ] like that i don't even know what
that is keto
just no uh carbs no sugar oh high fat
diet
i mean sugar is i don't really do too
much candy but i eat everything
well i'm gonna start worrying about
stuff like that when i get older i'm
only 23. so damn
you know 23 years old man yeah um
anybody else you want to
shed the spotlight on that's from your
from your city man that might not
be getting some love it's cats from the
south you know already know him be nails
cats from the north
um if cats don't know him you can
literally type in my name and just
scroll to related searches
um the bay area been doing anything
um um
who's some cash shout out some la cast
some kb
go get it i'm talking about stuff shout
out i know you don't know what you're
talking
about l.a guys i know you talking about
stockton you feel me i hear you but i'm
thinking of names
okay so i can be specific because if i
start mentioning a bunch of cats from
another hood i ain't missing out cats in
my hood that's disrespect
all right so i got to come correct so
shout out to
shout out quack shout out yay shout out
shout out a lot of homies that i'm
missing your name right now apologize
for that shout out to ebk hot boys
they're doing anything
shout out to sack rappers because you
know we like this i know you're talking
about stockton but sack is like this
yeah you know so shout out all them they
doing anything
um shout out bean from the bay you know
what i'm saying
um little bean um
man so many artists you actually know
it's on the fly so i can't really
i got you think of a lot of names um
so 2020 had to be crazy because you
you were coming off the hype of the
freestyle and then everything shuts down
did you like how did you or how i mean
we're still in the middle of a pandemic
obviously this [ __ ] ain't over yet but
how has it kind of affected the like
like the business for you
outside of probably going on the road
has it kind of like have you noticed any
sort of
difference in in in in like maybe
momentum or anything like that because
of
because of the pandemic right thank god
the industry changes streaming you know
and internet so it's ways around it
if i can't perform in front of your face
i can perform on live we can just
there's ways around it
but it did it did affect a lot because
you know you
want that time to go your fans can grow
yeah
you know what i'm saying you some people
need need that oh i'm gonna go to
houston perform this song and get boo so
you know like i need to change the tempo
right right right you know
yeah that's kind of part of the game
it's part of the game and a lot of
people missing that part in the game
that's why me i'm just like okay
streaming time and i'm just just
dropping songs man just keeping it
flooded keeping it flooded but
again back to the pros and cons like
this whole pandemic affected a lot but i
had a baby during it
i lost two good friends so i was
battling with a lot of demons inside
but all that's like internal i can
handle that
external like the hate from freestyle i
couldn't control that
so i'm just worried about what i can't
control my workout freestyle was 2019
right it was 2019 but
you that's where's that going it's going
20 21 oh yeah
i still get tagged in that [ __ ] to this
day man you ain't going nowhere it's
gonna be their favorite
yeah it's a viral moment that's what
vira is yeah that's just forever
yeah straight up yeah what was what was
um was there anybody who was like
that gave you negative feedback about it
that that uh might have like
that might have took you by surprise or
somebody who like we might know who you
kind of know
family blind could say no names that's
disrespect but family yeah but i still
love them to death
you feel me and then the old heads
obviously i mean all those this that's
necessary
all hitting me like what the [ __ ] are
you doing man what is this that's gonna
happen that's gonna happen regardless
i can still meet couple cats so i see he
said something that's old heads i'm like
man you know
it ain't gonna be no what's up you know
what i'm saying right right right
that's some real [ __ ] man well look the
album is uh january 29th
coming out man i got a new i got a
single drop in the dead album called
birthday girl finna go crazy
just killed this freestyle with you how
many uh how much music you're sitting on
i'm sure a lot
so i'll make i make 30 songs with four
albums so right now just unreleased
like 50 60. oh [ __ ] yeah so you have a
very busy year
very busy year yeah so go get the album
trap go get that album shout out my boy
simba in the back my boy simba's here
yep
um and then you got merch dropping right
yeah i got merch drop in the data album
working merch
like what's the website we create we're
still creating now okay let's go come
out the dead let's go come on
album we'll go send everybody link will
be in my bio and go check the new
freestyle we just did
it's uh it's it's coming out are we
gonna do this it'll be out like the day
after
it it'll be out soon yeah usually we
drop the interview then the freestyle
right shout out my family shout out my
brothers
okay for sure let me make a quick shout
out shout out my family shout out my
brothers shout out my mom's my daughter
my baby moms and her family shout out
everybody shout out everybody who
survived
and made the 2021 and all the black
people and all that all the minorities
all the whites everybody who survived
and who fighting shout out to biden
you know i'm saying i got a brand new
president in there um
i really want to say it's a lot of
upcoming artists don't quit don't let
don't let nobody stop you know what i'm
saying
because i'm gonna look back at this when
i'm older and really like okay
i'm becoming a man so just evolve with
your career straight up
grown man [ __ ] man boom that's beautiful
perfect man